this is dash & bash at the National
video game arcade originally I made it
for game city here two years ago and now
it's a well permanent partially
exhibition yes the game takes place on
these four screens with big green
buttons attached to them players get
given a card to look for with a picture
on it and then when the game starts
they'll see a bunch of cards flying
around the screen they need to find
which screen has their card on it and
bash a big button but as it goes on it
adds in different rules different twists
and things and all of these are there to
encourage people to move around the
space have to dodge and weave in and out
of each other maybe even push each other
around kind of bash each other out of
the way and so very you know I wanted to
make a game about your playing in a
physical space making physical contact
and yo everyone is moving a lot through
the game dash and bash was a sort of
follow-up to a game i did for big
touchscreens called tap happy sabotage
so tap happy sabotage took place on
earth of 27 inch touchscreen and instead
of you're looking for a button to press
to get your card you had to find it on
the touch screen and tap it and then it
would add in twist like you had to hold
free of your card at the same time or
you had to drag your card out on the way
over baddie bouncing around the screen
which also meant that you could grab
your opponent's cards and just throw
them into the body and so the idea with
that game is that every different kind
of round introduced some new twists and
with each twist there was both an opioid
there was the rules of how to play which
was a different kind of interaction with
the screen but that would also include a
way that you could mess up your
opponent's if you kind of spotted it the
thing I kind of learned through doing
all these work is that it's not about um
yo it's not about complex technology you
know it's not touch screens that make
the game it's not motion controllers
that make the game I mean these are just
big green buttons but what's change is
that creating your own electronics using
things like i use in arduino boards to
all of this stuff that makes it easy to
set up stuff that's never been made
before but it's all simple it so you
know everyone gets a button and it's
what you do with that that makes it
interesting behind the screen says a
desktop PC the buttons are all connected
up to an Arduino board and that's really
just taking in input and passing them on
to a computer it's got two graphics
cards in it and to HDMI outputs on each
graphics card and that's what's
outputting the signal to the screens the
Arduino is the fun bit because that's a
bit you know you can plug that pull that
out and plug that into other games and
you try making different games with the
same hardware but beyond that is just
standard computer kit really the game is
built in the Unity engine which oh yeah
I found has been very easy to work with
very malleable so yeah I kind of I
really like unity uh-huh and how long
did it take you to make what's the
process so the original tap happy
sabotage on the big touchscreens was
probably about two or three months in
development and then i would start
taking it on the road and taking it to
trade shows and games festivals watching
people play and just continually
tweaking it based on how people
interacted with it which bits click with
them which didn't click with them
so as anyone but your cards it's the
last one standing
continually improving that game bit by
bit for about six months before i
started work on this one this version
maybe took another month's work to get
you into the state where it works with
the four screens and arduino interface
and you've got the buttons and
everything and then to that to the game
city festival and during the festival i
was considerable continually making
tweaks based on people playing it there
and then and when people left the room I
would go in with a USB key and load in
the new version so I mean it's I think
that's the reality of game development
and particularly with stuff that is for
use in public spaces is that you don't
kind of have a development period yo you
test it out in secret and then you go
it's ready let's launch it you know you
often have to go out with the prototype
and try it out on real people as if it's
the finished product just to see how it
works and then you expand it based off
of what you learn it's the sort of
evolution is definitely yes and if
people are interested in playing these
games is this sort of venue the only
place you could play again with it um so
dashing bash is only here at the
National videogame arcade I've also you
know I will often be at games events and
festivals sort of touring around codecs
bash which is another game i'm showing
here i'm working on a project at the
moment to to do a playable sage show so
first version of this show I've been
running here at the game city festival
and you know I want to turn that into
something bigger and kind of roll that
out into new venues and so really it is
a case of tracking me down catching me
wherever I am but hopefully you know as
I take it to more places people will
start to say Who I want a copy of list
for this venue I'll say okay I can
rustle you up one and you know maybe
we'll see a few more of them so watch
this space I guess
we'd like to thank audible.com for
sponsoring computer file and for you
guys audible is offering a free book
with a 30-day free trial all you need to
do is go up to audible.com / computer
file sign up download a book and start
listening it's that easy now today I
like to recommend seven Eve's by Neal
Stephenson I have to confess I'm a fan
of Neal's work anyway and i also have to
confess that i'm still halfway through
70s but it's a fantastic idea it's
gripping it starts with the moon the
Earth's moon breaking into pieces and
scientists predict that within certain
maybe it's two years that the moon will
cause the earth to be uninhabitable so
they have to work out who's going to
survive by leaving the planet or whether
going to go underground and how many
people will leave the planet if so and
how just how they'll survive in space so
great book check out seven teams by Neal
Stephenson and thanks once again to
audible for sponsoring computer Val it
really does make a difference the other
two canisters are actually butane
cylinders which were discarded and they
act kind of like a gas capacitor the
cool accumulators and they store gas
close to where it comes out so that it
can come out quickly